谢谢大家我好久没有假市场新年快乐
然后过年的时候自己在那里所以我没有假市场
然后我觉得先总结一下二月份的整个市场的动向吧
然后说一下我对后面一段时间的看法
其实从红花上来讲的话
就我是觉得在短期里面市场是需要经过调整
这其实在一月份的时候我其实已经讲过这个问题了
就是整个市场的Position
就是这个Position叫什么仓位
仓位和那个设置
他的设置包括他的Gama的情况
Gama我的情况
其实都是对市场不是很有利的
那二月份跌了这么少其实有点出货意料
就是一月份的时候我其实觉得
整体红光我们对长期是非常看好
就是整个AIS还是很看好
但是在短期的Position和整个Setup上面
这个市场是需要经过调整
但是一直没有调整下去
二月份一句话来总结吧
就二月份 was like a long year
就是他经过了很多geopolitical的影响
然后剧多的不确定性
然后这从红花上来讲剧多不确定性
但是从微环上说
市场开始意识到
AI不光是很甜蜜的capacity
然后给公司增加盈利
然后市场装爱风开始意识到了
那个AI对原来行业的冲击
而且在比较快的时间里面
市场从这部分的恐惧
从AI从个股扩散到指数
主要是比较是软件的指数
然后也扩散到信用的市场
所以其实AI对于市场的负面影响
在二月份的时候给大家尝试了一下
我觉得这个东西还没有开始
一个工业革命级的东西出现
像AI是一个工业革命级的东西出现
必然是一将成名万股
不光是取代很多人的工作
然后又取代很多行业和很多的公司的
所以我先说一下二月份
其实最近市场大家关注的比较多的
就是美国跟伊朗的矛盾
然后这个战争的问题会维持多久
其实也不太确定
但是我们知道的是
他们通过Palantir的技术
或者是通过一些本来的情报
和结合Palantir的技术
在战争的第一天把对方的领导人全部干掉
其实这个预示着未来战争的一个形式
我之前其实在说到
我哪为他事件是我已经讲过这个问题
这个不是光情报工作
是有大量的数据整理
然后人没有办法处理的AI的大量的数据
所以以后国防部的订单
你们不能预期全部给到飞机堂
和给到罗克希拉马顶
其实AI和我们叫软件层
AI和新的国防订单
包括Palantir
包括很多无人机公司
都会把他的比率扩张很多
美国的国防部订单是6000亿美元
然后他的Palantir作为他的软件供货商
或者他整个operated system的1%都没有拿到
就是我说整个国防部直接支出
所以这个格局是会改变的
因为你虽然看他一第一天发了1400多个导弹
然后起家了很多飞机
但是AI在这个战争中间的作用
是超过50%了
就是能够在第一天把你领导成全看掉
以后AI可以克制战争
因为你发起战争
这个领导就会先走
以后战争的形态都会变成这样子
不太需要地面武装这样去推动
但是这个东西背后
其实是二月份结合二月份在美国
有大量的新闻
大量的正面和负面的新闻
包括我们之前觉得比较担心
一月份就开始出现了比较担心的艾斯的问题
然后导致了大量的美国国内的民众的抗议
接着引出Trump的Appson file
然后这个里面
这个事情被司法部长到
我会作证的时候变成了一个焦点
他说他在那里defend Trump和整个议会在吵架
然后又有那个特朗普的关税被推翻
他的支持率到了新低
其实我深耗觉得
他在伊朗发动这个东西
也不是中国国内说的
他要什么美元把权要获得石油美元
我不是讲他国内的矛盾太多了
他需要就这个人
我我不知道
就是我觉得国内矛盾太多
也是一个很重要的原因
需要把那个而且支持率实在太低了
Supreme Court推翻了Trump的关税
Trump用那个122加了MG15
150天150天一个20天
然后可以重新去重新去
那个去去调查那个美国国家关税
然后给那个给美国国家再加上去
其实你们可以这样理解
因为对于关税的事情
我们之前讲过
就是虽然一把是最简单的加关税的办法
但是如果Trump想去给大家
把关税重新加回来的
他肯定是可以重新加回来
只是一把是最简单的办法
Supreme Court最高法院
虽然是推翻了这次的关税
但是最高远其实也确认了
就是说关税是Executive Branch的事情
就是他那个
他可以通过Executive Branch的其他的
122 301这些东西继续去加关税
所以我觉得就是你15%
对于原来那些被取消的
一盘下面被取消的
Executive Sheriff其实没有特别大的变化
但是这些事情
整起来说给市场带来的是不确定性
也就是现在市场处于一个非常差的Position
你能说Position一定是影响短期的
它不是影响超级长期
等于说在一个月或者是在这段时间里面
是一个非常差的Position
这Position是怎么样的
就是说你可以看到Kalker Plus Queue差了很多
也就是说市场上有很多人在那里买Pold Option
买往下的期权
不光是在股票市场上
你会看到在
现在我们看到这个是在那个快列市场
就是在信用站上去买Pold也很多
就是大家都在对冲一个往下的极端风险
Pold Queue很大意味着Pold Option很贵
那说明也没有人愿意卖
这个很容易理解
你也不太愿意在这个位置上去卖Pold
因为你不知道明天
是不是又跟谁打起来然后要怎么样
所以不确定性
那时候你卖Pold的这个杆子就没有那么大
那么下面的Option就会变得很贵
然后买的人多
投行的Position投行的仓位是Naked Gamma
就在现在这个位置上是Naked Gamma
但是往上7000点是有个Gamma
我就是往上的时候
Core大家是愿意卖的
卖Core是愿意
因为觉得你也不一定涨上去
涨上去就是反正我卖Core就正常卖
那么这个呢导致了就是
我们看二月份的整体的资金的流动
就是机构在卖出
机构卖出是包括两个方面
一个是低了
一个是能低了
就是一个是投资银行的对冲
一个是主动的基金的卖出
其实两方面都是在卖出的
投行的卖出就是一种
就是当股票在涨的时候
上面有个Gamma
就是如果股票在涨投行对冲盘是卖出的
股票在跌的话
因为下面的Naked Gamma
现在Naked Gamma
第二去Naked Gamma
会变得更加严重一点
所以它会加速卖出
就跌的时候就卖得更多
所以你会看到在二月份的时候
股票的指数就是
它每次上涨的时候慢慢恢复
涨到7000年的Gamma
我涨不上去
然后我说的Only way is down from here
是我觉得市场需要经过一轮调整
能够更好的就是涨出新高篮
就是你如果你那个市场肯定是
我是看多了
但是你是需要一个需要一轮调整
才能够涨下去
但是在二月份的时候
一直试图调整调整不动
每一次下跌会非常快速
下跌的时候投行也在卖
然后现在CTA好像已经好
我CTA投行就跌了
现在CTA好像已经好一点
但是那个从二月份来看的话
CTA是一条往下的线
就是当你flat的时候
它不涨不跌的时候
它是卖卖卖出
然后如果是它那个跌的话
它是会卖很多
涨的话是买一点点
大概是这个样子
它是不太平均的那个CTA
所以你会看到的
市场的方向是说投资银行
在跌的时候加速在卖
然后因为volatility变高了
然后vote变高了
那个每次下跌都很快
所以CTA也没有办法继续加长
然后vote control我们叫systematic position
也没有办法继续加长
所以我们从三个角度来看
一个是低了
一个是难低了的基金
然后一个是比较说systematic position
就是CTA和vote control那些人
其实都是在卖出的
那么谁在买路呢
这个就是基金的仓位
基金的仓位你会看到
从十月份到现在一直在加长
对于NASDAQ的一直在加长
但NASDAQ和S&P没怎么动
那为什么呢
因为retail一直在买
就是这个是retail就散户
所以我们看到散户的买路的热情
是enormous的
非常非常大的
就是这个背后为什么是
你可以看到美国很多高科技公司
NASDAQ指数的公司
它的估值已经非常低了
包括那个比方说微软
它估值已经和去年四月份差不多
所以我们会看得到
就是在Warspere上
看那个大部分的机构的仓位
就是他们都在卖出
但是散户在买路
那么
能低了卖了多少
能低的大概卖了
二月份卖了6.7个别领
167亿美元
然后systematic卖出了
就是CTA那些卖出了26个别领
systematic
就是你会看到一个
我们在一月份讲的问题是
坦口的流动性变小
然后投行的对冲是助涨杀跌
现在投行对冲是
涨上去的还也是要卖
就投行对冲都是下跌的
然后CTA也是要卖出的
因为CTA因为波动力变大
CTA卖出
所有的卖出的压力
在二月份被消化掉
它竟然没有跌下去
正常情况下
如果放在2000年这种需要
已经已经结束了
已经暴跌了
就是它竟然没有跌下去
因为它估值其实很低
公司的earning
熬口经济的基本面
大家看得到的基本面
包括在
3月份4月份
美国要退税
要退一千亿
然后大部分的退税
其实是在3月份完成
大部分退税
其实在4月份完成
就是还没有
还没有迪勒奔
然后3月份
拿到评价数吧
我们看到要退税退一千亿
所以散户买入的情势非常高
就是这个是目前市场的国益
那么高英方
从这个点下去
我觉得一个比较健康的是应该要调整一下
因为包括我们看到CES spread
也已经开始出来了
这个是让我会比较更加担心一点的吧
就是在短期里面更加担心一点
因为这个代表着
AI对于不同行业的伤害
都已经到信用层面了
所以这个是真正会影响市场的
因为当快乐 spread上去以后
你们会看到在alloc上发生的事情
当快乐 spread放上去以后
它要继续做capacity 卖东西了
然后它融资就没有那么容易
然后它可能要去融股票了
所以这些都是可能会去要影响到股价的
当然alloc是一个很单独的例子
因为这个cdx
这个是investment grade
是ig
cdxig是相当于所有投资级的
那个信用集差在并告
这是一个比较危险的性
这个代表着市场
所有私营部门的流动性
那个或者是获得资金的这个成本
那么为什么它会开始影响呢
其实就原来AI都是说助推奖
然后最近对于AI继续助推
比方说半导体的这个这个
这个是半导体对于那个软件的一个
买卖这个exposure
就是prample
就是prample就是对那个
Hatch房对冲基金啊
对于他们的这个exposure
就是大家不很大的热情
在卖出所有的软件公司
因为原来软件公司
你给给到的都是30倍evae大
为什么愿意给你30倍evae大
是因为我觉得你未来每年
能够增长15%到20
但是这个增长15%到20
它被AI可能会证稳
也就是说你没有办法
证实自己以后能够增长15%到20
你的业绩今年再好
他们会觉得anthropic
OpenAI以后能取代你
这个事情我可能在上一集
其实找到我这个问题
在软件的这个当账下面
你每一次市场上
就会原来是
蓄势是辅助你的业绩
当你有业绩的时候
你去讲故事去蓄势
然后然后这个蓄势
会助长你的业绩
现在想法
也就是在很多情况下
包括对于软件
它是先蓄势
然后业绩去辅助蓄势的
你在蓄势不好的时候
大家觉得你会被AI
被新制生产力替代的时候
你的软件行业
你业绩再好也没有用
因为你业绩好
你只能证明现在业绩好
你不能证明你未来一年
两年 三年 五年
你不被OpenAI
或者anthropic
或者是那个gemite他们取代
这个是没有人能够做到这个证明的
那相反的话
有很多公司
比方说我他会讲
比方说CPU的那些公司
或者是光芒坏的那些公司
他哪怕业绩没有很好
但是他在蓄势里面
就是大家觉得在未来AI需要
就是AI里面会需要你这个东西
他哪怕业绩没有这么好
大家有时候会拿二八年的业绩
觉得你未来会好
然后来给你定价
就是现在因为巨大的这行业的kios
在于我确实是不确定AI会对市场
造成什么样的东西
那么在短期对红官的话
其实至少在2月份吧
AI对于市场的负面影响
是远远超过这面影响
1月份2月份
其实这个趋势并没有被改变
就是大家SARS和原来是说
AI影响可能个别公司
从个别公司影响到整个软件
或者SARS的行业
现在我觉得它从整个软件和SARS的行业
就扩展到 扩展到所有2C端
这个我好像2月份也说了这个问题
就是比方说协产
你没有任何价值
对吧
你如果你的价值在于
你有个前端2C的工具
然后有个团运营的团队
然后对接了5到6加大的OTA的API对接
然后其实Enthopia OpenAR可以直接对接了
然后它的那个使用体验会比你好
那你们以后就变成一个
就是把很多2C 把2C的
或者是有2C AF的这些工具
变成一个后台服务的东西
就是如果协产要做
它可以做一个最后台服务的东西
所以这些公司是在AI时代
没有任何价值的
就应该全部所提出
全部被淡量
其实这个中间包括美团
你可以做一个后台管理
但是对前端它是要被取代
也就是所有当你的业务模式是C2C的时候
就是两边都是人
你可能没有被影响
像微信啊
像那个Facebook啊
像那个Meta这种
你可能没有被影响
因为两边都是人
当你一边是人
一边是content provider
一边你是内容的时候
那你这个公司就应该直接被AI取代
因为AI读取内容的速度和效率
是跟你不是在一个量级上
也就是原来你比方说百度
你要去建立一个content cool
就是建立那个内容库
你说百度当时是做搜索
国内搜过也做过搜索对吧
然后其实小米也做过搜索
很多人做过搜索都做不出来
因为他有个团队去爬了所有的
这些网站和内容
然后把内容库做得非常好
所以把谷歌跑掉
他把谷歌给踢出去了
但是你其他人要去竞争他
其实竞争不了
其实从内容上没有办法竞争
另外content provider在他那里
他有这方面的优势
但是以后大家对话的是模型
模型读取API能力是超过你的
所以他的模型的优势
就是可以瞬间的处理
大规模的数据量
然后把无需的这些数据
瞬间找出东西来给你
那原来你建立的这些content
就我们叫CP
就是内容的库就没有价值了
这个不光是协厂 百度
很多2C的美国SARS的软件
或者是大量的提供
一方面提供内容的这些公司
其实都要被扫地出门
所以这个很快
包括保险
所有互联网上提供保险的
甚至还不是互联网上提供保险
提供金融产品
就是推翻米门的门卡会变得很低
最近在规故有一个说法
就说AI是什么
AI是一个红宝书
就是文化大革命的红宝书
发一本红宝书给你
你就可以造反
原来可能需要上百人团队干的事情
可能几个人的团队就能做出来
就是你不能想象
比方说我现在我们三五个人的团队
要去做一个搜索内容的东西
比方说聊天的工具
它可以做到肯定超过你
肯定超过你copilot
可以肯定的超过国内你所有的软件
因为后面有AI的模型
它是开源的
它API可以给你调用的
然后你调用它的API
你就是直接获得了OpenAI的能力
或者实验照片的能力
所以这个是有很恐怖的东西
是过去二十年TMP公司建立的
所有的互惩和门槛
在瞬间被推到
你的固执瞬间在消失的过程中间
市场其实是恐惧的
就是这个是市场的恐惧
那在市场恐惧的另外一面
我们看到是巨大的机会
巨大的机会存在在谁头上
前端存在谁头上
其实不知道今年AI是大恐战
就大概率就那几个
我上次讲的那几个模型
最后谁音出来也不知道
但是大概率
你可以回去听一下我
一个月前一个视频
然后就是讲到这几个模型
就是我是觉得这几个模型中间
可能会跑出来一个未来
但是前端其实并不知道
但是所有的模型最终都是需要
那个算力的
所以Again
我觉得那些提供算力的公司
你只要在提供算力的路径上
那这些公司都不过有特别大的问题
我说了很多就是关于那个市场的
非关的情绪
就是说短期的Position是需要去调整的
因为你从Position上变了或变了很长
那么在这个Position有没有改善
从2月份到现在3月初
其实没有改善
就是没有特别大的改善
NectarGamma情况还是持续的
因为大家没有人
现在弄出这么多不决定型
没有人敢去在下面MinePort
这个事情要到什么时候改善
我觉得两种情况
第一个就是外
你不停的在买下面的Protection
卖这些保险
你在买保险的时候
其实你一直在承受相当于Tie Value算
是NectarGamma叫NectarGamma
就是付的现金流支出
你要让这批人亏购钱需要时间
市场现在一直没有跌下去
所以那些人其实也在亏钱
买保险也在亏钱
那样是亏购钱
然后第二种就是市场迅速的调整到位
调整到位你真的跌下去的Wall上来了
Wall涨得更高了
那么已经跌下去以后
那自然就会有人在下面MinePort
原来市场过去两年的setup是
有很多人在MineCore
也有很多人在MinePort
两边都有人在Mine
然后市场会被压在中间
就是波动会变得很小
不像现在往下波动很大
往上不波动
然后那个因为Wall变得很小
所以CTA Wall Control会加康感
就是有更多的钱进去买
就等于买指数
这个指数是被压成一条直线
慢慢往上涨
你看过去两年都是这个样子
然后过一段时间调整一次
那现在Portation Setup不是这样的
我们认为至少未来一个月
或者为了一段时间的一个new norm
如果它不跌下去的话
就是在上面有个钢瓦卧
它很难冲破
在七千点它很难冲破
因为很简单
没有那么多傍晚资金进去了
因为你可以看SystemMinePort
卖出来26个别点
你得用同样的钱买进去
他们不会加康感
因为波动率不是很小
那你不会加康感的话
那它的网上冲破卡
我是需要很大的资金量
它不够
然后但是往下跌的时候
它会跌得很快
然后跌三五个点
跌很快
然后被retail或者被超级的钱马上来
因为本质美国经济资本面是很强的
然后又有退税
又有那个financial deregulation
financial deregulation这件事情
不同银行有不同的预期
高盛预期大概有5万亿美元
就是增加可借款
就银行的增加可借款
然后两千亿美元左右的资本金的注入
等同于两千亿美元的资本金注入
解评我本觉得
大概在银行风完前以后
两点八万亿左右
所以总之它是在4月1号
可以被implement新的ESLR之后
市场的资金流动性
资金面是不差的
包括你们看financial condition index
FCI它也一直在变好
所以你从大的时间
更长时间的基本面来看
包括美国经济基本面都不剩差
包括你觉得它会不会有通胀
它也不太会有通胀
不要觉得打了仗
石油怎么样就美国造成通胀
这个不是这样的传递这个方法
真正美国担心的通胀是service
是工资螺旋上升
这个看不到的
就是现在事业的情况
看不到工资螺旋上升
所以不管伊朗这边打仗打多久
美国要产生通胀
然后导致联储加息被影响
这个事情我觉得可能性不是太大
然后而且石油其实没有反应那么大
反应比较大的是天然气
对欧洲影响过
我觉得会对美国大很多
对欧洲对日本对中国影响
都会对美国大
其实这个打仗
它是在别人别人的毛坑里丢块砖头
对他对美国影响是最小的
就是我一个不太相当比远
然后所以长期上
我觉得是比较乐观的
然后但是短期的position相对来说
相对来说比较差一点
然后我回过头讲算力的问题
就是你们可以看这个图
这个大概是我过前段时间看到
就是这个对上一段时间
我正好也讲过的就是这个也是一样的
就说这个是H100
这里是A100的把A100的那个卡加上去
就是在1月份以后
12月份以后
不光是H100的族群
A100的族群都在长
就是老的卡H100
24年就有了
然后这些卡早就回本了
去年年中
可能就回本了
然后回本了卡
它的族群一直在上升
现在可能到2045这样子
所以大家到2045左右
所以你会看到在AI时代
你相当于发了红宝书让所有人去造反
那这些人都要去调动算力的
对于token的需求是指数就在上升
那么我觉得这个AI现在已经过了
我们Galaxy Reality Point
就是那个奇异点
就是它一个到了这个点
没有办法再回头的点
是真正过了奇异点
其实是今年
就是当AI真的能够实现生产力了
也代表就是OpenAI和anthropic
对于b端的收益在增加
就是收入在大量的增加
那么一个月可能增加了10个亿左右
然后anthropic其实也是吧
这两家你可以把这两家的这个
整个收入放在一起来计算
所以今年可能他们要做到500亿以上
我觉得很有可能两家家一起
就是会做到500亿以上
那么这个500亿是哪里出来的
就回到我们之前一直讲的这个问题
是SARS出来的
还是tmp公司出来的
还是很多人工作出来的
我觉得是SARS Accompanation
但是即使今年做到500亿
都只是刚刚开始
就是它后面的earning会变得更大
那么对于token的需求
对于半导体的需求
也会很恐怖的
就是这个本质是没有变化
华尔街真正担心的是
就是是不是你们
AI是很好
但是不是你们
就包括hyperscale
你们在做大量的capax
会不是影响到你们的balance sheet
那么对于短期
对于AI公司最大的很大的这个担心
就是hyperscale的几个大公司的
它的这个对于capax的投入吧
已经到92%的开始了
所以明年你还能不能投
这个是一直压着比方说英伟达
就是你提供算力的人能够获得
就是谁提供算力
就是你AI时代
你们知道token的需求是很大吧
那在token需求很大的时候
是谁在提供算力呢
其实这个算力中间
可能有一半是软件产生的
就是我们说opening or anthropic
他们都然后剩下的里面
可能有大部分有四六开吧
有六成是英伟达的集成导致
就是包括英伟达或tpu的集成导致
那么在这个在剩下那个四十里面
可能是有一半是covers
那么叫advance package
就是把不同的芯片合在一起弄了
然后最后才是三纳米两纳米
这个流片的工艺
就是tsmc
当然最后两道都是tsmc做的
前道的那个packaging
和那个dye都是tsmc做的
然后中间当然还包括了
不光是packaging的这个dye对吧
然后还有就是两水hbm啊
然后光模块
所以我觉得是这整个提供算力的人
在AI里面都
AI这个这个周期里面都应该获得收益
那么唯一一个就回头讲一下
英伟达业绩非常好
但是为什么业就好了
他补偿
因为市场担心大家KAPEX做不下去了
今年已经到了6600亿了
就加大公司KAPEX
达到这些公司92%的现金流了
然后使得这些公司的股票回购
因为其实股票回购
还是支撑美股的一个很重要的原因
那个今年317个别链
那个股票回购
其实对整个市场支撑还是很重要的
那么但是
他对于稀后的value return
从43到16
这个就是他们要去投KAPEX
所以减少的对稀后的return正常正常
那么这个是市场就比较担心的一个点
就是我们AI确实需求很大
Token需求也很大
但是谁还继续去买你英伟达的这个
小型大型机呢
然后要需要hype scale去做KAPEX
那么hype scale叫我们没钱了
你怎么办
其实就是要等到
我觉得两个成型
两个起一点
一个起一点是AI的起一点
这个事情已经发生了
因为Obi and Dolby
已经generate大量revenue
第二个起一点是
不断不断投入的起点
就是要等到这些鱼银厂
它的收入增加
开始超过它KAPEX增加
那么这个在今年是完成不了的
因为明确的
这完成不了的情况下
你的KAPEX占到92%
大家会觉得你明年没钱投了
你明年有钱投
后年也没钱投
那谁去买那个英伟达的这个机房呢
这个才是市场对于它的担心
但是呢
其实到了今年年二季度
就会慢慢被证稳
就是大家知道
哪怕KAPEX增速在下降
英伟达引力还是要增加50%
那这个原因就是
因为这两年
二五二六年两年的投资
中间有一半是搞了土建
就是建了机房
土建是百分之
你们说KAPEX的时候
其实不太分开
但是买卡还是造房子
就是我是造了这个房子以后
再把卡放进去对吧
这个卡放进去的收益
是一年半回本
然后回本以后
它最近还在涨
这个是H100
这条钱是H100
然后买卡是B系列的卡
一旦部署
一旦买了部署
立马就会被租完
然后很长时间都租约到底
这个是买卡
所以买卡其实是可以达到现金流
有现金流
你看到KAPEX没现金流投资
因为他买了房子
这造了房子
你得把房子造好才能买卡
那个房子是20年
所以当你减少KAPEX投入的
增加的速度的时候
我们会在明年看到
NVIDIA的Earning它没有变
它的增速也未必会变
这个时候以前很恐怖的事情
所以我觉得在AI的这时代
你要么就是能够看准
到底谁产生效率
就是谁产生
说实话就是AI时代是把电变成脑力
取代现在7亿脑力劳动者
中间的一半
可能一半的人
然后这些全部都是
然后全部要
以后除了最最精英的那些人
你在中间的那些智力劳动者
是没有任何价值的
然后你在这个过程中间
其实就是把电变成脑力
然后把电变成脑力
就是谁提供了算力
就是才有价值
这四家是提供了一半的算力的
就是算力的提高
提高了一半算力提高
然后剩下就是那些半导提供4
半导提供4就是英伟达
我刚刚讲英伟达
然后到后面
TSMC
谷歌的GPU是跟英伟达是一并平行的
然后阿巴沟
然后下面比较说光母宽成储
然后CPU
然后最后花三分钟时间说一下CPU
就是过去大家认知CPU是替代GPU
GPU是替代GPU
你是站在纽维连的对立面
那你就应该完蛋
然后但是现在
因为这么多的AZEN的使用
就特别是今年进入七年以后
这么多的AZEN使用
其实CPU这个东西
就是会变成英伟达
这个整个Rack大型机的一个配件
就GPU是个配件
CPU也是个配件
光母宽也是配件
HBM也是它的配件
你这么远远地理解
因为AZEN大量调用以后
它就会需要更多的CPU
你把GPU当成是一个工厂工人
那CPU是车间主任
就是你调配活的那个人
你更多的活进来的时候
车间主任会后面更忙
在
它从Grace升级到Vara
这两个芯片都是ARM加过的
其实很有
因为ARM加过没有问题
因为现在前端使用的都是Labs
那么他们那个技术能力很强
用ARM没有问题
但是很多客户其实要用X86加过
所以很有可能的就是
会就是
NVIDIA会和Intel一起推一个
X86加过的这个卡
就CPU的卡
我觉得这个概率很大
可能会很快
所以
其实我之前决定因为的那个
像Intel它没有
就纪念很难有业绩
它的业绩可能要在
27年28年
然后才会出来
所以我绝对把Intel讲
它也讲了挺多的
然后我最近也在反思这个问题
就是我刚刚讲的
像CPU参与了算力更新的
它其实是在蓄势上面
它没有办法在纪念业绩证明它
但是问题它是在蓄势上的
它跟很多SARS的公司是在对地面
另外一面SARS公司是没有
没有蓄势只有业绩
那个它还是要死
但是问题在AI上面
就是像Intel它是在蓄势上
所以
这个参与我们可能会密切关注
特别是关注GTC后面
会不会推新的芯片出来
我觉得概率很大
好
然后今天大概就讲一下
整个市场的赛达会
然后讲一下关于AI的东西
我可能时间不够了
我今天就不装QNL了
谢谢大家
大家新年快乐